Blue Beetle though it was made before
James Gunn's big reboot is said to be
will vaguely part of James Gunn's DC
Universe smart to say that since saying
hey the new movie coming out it doesn't
matter it's getting rebooted anyway
causes people to not go watch your new
movie get what you're doing DC at least
they're learning from their mistakes
respectable
[Music]
it's a Blue Beetle a new DC movie also a
character I don't know much about
outside of Injustice 2. gonna be honest
with you Pony is a robotic world ending
death Scarab from outer space latches
onto a dude he becomes Blue Beetle and
now he's gotta you know save the day
also family now sholomai duenya is
delayed in this film he's the Blue
Beetle I mean he's he's the heart and
soul of Cobra Kai has been since the
first season and he does bring that
energy here obviously he plays a very
different character but still has that
essence of
seems like a good kid I mean it's weird
to call him a kitty isn't his 20s but
I'm just saying he has that essence of
you know he he seems nice from people
who have interviewed him they say he's
nice just as a human in a film like this
especially one that heavily revolves
around a family Dynamic you want someone
you can relate to and be like hey we're
rooting for you here he does bring that
to the character I'm saying that's when
it's him the face we know the human
we're rooting for that's when the films
actually had its best when he becomes
the big bad Beetleborg it just feels
like a lot of superhero stuff we've seen
a lot of which is kind of funny the Blue
Beetle characters actually I think he's
from 1939 kind of ironic to me that a
character that's so old just in the
echelon of comic book characters has a
movie that feels like it's borrowed so
much from other comic book characters
movies but the family Dynamic was really
the heart and soul of the film though it
was a little tonally inconsistent there
are moments where it feels like this
movie was made to be a more hardcore
version of itself and they were like
maybe we should Market this towards kids
a little more
let's change the music in a couple
scenes that'll help then it was
transformation scene his transformation
scene in the trailer looks intense
you're like oh my God I would freak out
if that happened to one of my family
members or we can make jokes have a
lighthearted song choice to go with it
sure I'm not saying a movie has to take
itself too seriously I'm running out of
ways to say it because that's a very
common complaint I have where it's like
the movie was too light-hearted made
jokes at the wrong time there were
characters that did work with like with
the grandma was like full pass that
works because that's kind of ironic and
amazing granny kicking ass with a
Gatling gun just works what can I say it
does feel a little campy in the way it
just kind of lingers on it for a little
longer than it needs to but what can I
say I was having fun with that also
George Lopez I thought was great in the
movie too I mean he is a seasoned
comedian and comedic actor so absolutely
he does crush it in that respect that's
kind of my point in a world where a lot
of these comic book movies want to make
everything funny the seasoned comic
knows how to do it and have the comedy
not overstay it's welcome and in terms
of drama gotta give credit where
credit's due there was one scene in
particular I was like that worked that
was good job movie
you did it and there was another moment
with another character came later in the
film I liked that one too could have
gone for more of it involving that
character but I digress as for the
baddies you have Susan surrounding
playing passive aggressive racist CEO
Karen Baddie then you have another dude
who looks like he was plucked straight
from cyberpunk 2077. as for cyberpunk
2077-ish body I thought he was the most
interesting character in the movie until
he starts fighting Blue Beetle and then
he becomes something out of Tron and
then he's just less interesting he's
just a big robot looking thing fighting
Blue Beetle could have gone for an
entire film revolving around him to be
completely honest with you who knows
maybe we can still get it yeah this
movie definitely does have a mask
problem it's like oh human face is great
characters then masks come on they start
fighting oh okay well it just feels like
everything I've seen before a
fucktillion times at this point I did
like how the family was way more
hardcore Than Blue Beetle was you know
it's because the suit can kind of make
anything so it's like oh we can make you
want to wipe baddies out here are some
guns he's like no guns no killing it's
like Batman or something his family
though yeah they end lives they'll kill
folk doesn't matter I don't know you
think they talk about it at the barbecue
do you think he's like well I I
definitely have a thing against killing
people and you all absolutely do not I
kind of feel a certain way about that it
kind of came across as an inconsistency
that the movie makes a point to be like
killing is bad and that's a thing with
Blue Beetle his family though they will
put folks in the ground and no one cares
look in the end like I said I thought
sholomai duenya I thought he was great
as the lead he brings that likability
that you've seen in Cobra Kai and he
brings it here in comic book movie form
I just feel like I've seen this movie
before in the form of a few other movies
granted most movies out there are a
frankenstitch of at least a couple other
movies woven together to make something
seemingly new but in the comic book
movie subgenre it's easier to notice
when your movie seems to be pulling from
a few other comic book movies for the
most part this film felt like it would
have been great if it came out in 2000
four there's some stiff competition out
there and the elements you see in here I
feel like you can get in other comic
book movies that have done it better
maybe it'll be a better time if you're
drunk yeah no it's a party alright so
Blue Beetle have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]